drinks okay is it working now yes okay
so we are being recorded so can I just
remind people that we are being recorded
and I will go through this because it's
part of the meeting so good evening
everyone should we be required to
evacuate the building would you please
leave the building via the nearest
available exit there is one fire exit in
this room if you need to evacuate the
room do so by the glass door to the
external fire escape staircase please
hold both handrails in case the stairs
are wet or slippery if anyone is unable
to use the stairs would they please
allow others to exit the room before
they go to the fire escape door where
they can then be given assistance our
assembly point will be in the public
carpark at the side of the Civic suite
please do not delay your evacuation to
collect any belongings please do not
return to the building until given
permission to do so by council staff and
please note this meeting will now be
audio recorded and I please remind you
to switch off your mobile phones or turn
them to silent apologies for absence I
think we're all here aren't we
mister no apologies non-members
attending and I believe they're already
minutes of the meeting zone on the 12th
of July is it your wish that I sign them
as a true record right no no other
points from those minutes that are no it
was wearing the agenda thank you any
declarations of interest please should
any arise during the meeting please say
them and we'll make sure they
administered at that time
all right so items 5 their matters
referred to the executive and reports
from other committees there are none so
we'll go straight to the 2020 vegetable
which is item 6 are you presenting this
George
and then enjoy a lovely Thank You
members this report suggests that the
legal certainly might as ceremonial is
the beginning of a is the beginning of a
month on series of fist festivals
disabilities which celebrates a number
of other equally as fresh is
anniversaries throughout the district
this will be the discover twenty to
twenty first of all the report proposes
to establish a tourism forum which will
oversee and convey at a rate the
discover 2020 physical as the first step
in building a tourism strategy for the
council and the visitors economy for the
whole district de terre a tourism forum
will be that the partnership between the
council and partners across the business
and voluntary communities and launch
event has been set for the 11th of
October which will be first the first
opportunity to work with these partners
and agree the details of they discovered
2020 first of all this launch will be
held at the fairytales and invitations
have been sent out this is not about the
council taking over all the fun funding
League discovered 2020 festival by
itself the festival must be a
partnership
colleagues from business and volunteers
but it is about the council being the
catalyst for the development of a
business economy which benefits our
residents and our businesses if members
so wish have any questions these as the
treating director would be pleased tanks
thank you
what anything you what do you say any
questions but it's intended that that
will be essentially the launch event of
individual projects these individual
events will be owned by the community
okay thank you very much I say and I
think I've said to you before I was
amazed at the amount of things that
you've actually uncovered in the local
area all the different things and
anniversaries etc that are coming
forward particularly about son Andrews
Minster up in Ashington because it would
be the thousandth year there and the
connection with the crowning of the king
and indeed the connection with the
Bayeux Tapestry
which I wasn't aware of who you actually
discovered that which is amazing so you
know I'm really pleased with that
only it goes back to the thing like
you'd in which trials etc which you know
the infamous things that have happened
locally and some of the smuggling etc so
you know I think we live in an area
that's steeped in history you know but
not not least the Tudor times when it
came into prominence so it's great to
see all that coming out and China I
think can raise the profile of Rochford
and certainly raise it with our own
residents because I think a lot of
residents aren't aware that we've got
down here you know and the sort of place
that they live in in the history for
instance the raid amount you know I'm
not sure how many people know about rail
email coming forward and what it
represented at the time which is a good
example of a Norman Cape at the time so
you know it's it's you know there's lots
and lots of examples anyway any any
points anybody wanted to raise please
and I think please yeah
[Music]
I'll go careful
[Music]
[Music]
I think this is opener come hopefully
coming up when we have our conference
you know we can get some real detail
yeah
[Music]
geoffrey chaucer who was here sorry
Shawn you wanted to come here we want to
do something this century but I think
it's be worth just noting that there is
a lot of effort going into the Essex
partnership there are various it's being
spawned active will be the very least we
should we should keep you know this in
play in terms of in terms of what the
partnership is doing and the media
opportunities there to actually build
further on we're absolutely its own the
onion did you watch just a very minor
point really in 3.31
mentions do you have thousands
anniversary
I think I'll put up with that government
the only other thing I was going to say
is that if we are planning any events
clearly there are many grants available
out there various things and clearly we
need to make sure if money or help is
available or even sponsorship is
available we really need to go down that
route as best we can the other side one
thing that's not honest is my job so
that would better attend am isn't it but
there you are
so as I say it's a great paper it's it's
short and sweet and that's exactly what
we want but let's hope we can get a real
sort of diary going and make sure that
we